zootopia uh you play a fox in this film
this is your first animated film which
surprised me i i would you you have nice
pipes
i would think you'd you'd get more thank
you um
you know let's talk about will arnett
again this is a gentleman who does a
great deal of voice over work
with his beautiful pipes yes i think we
have a this is my favorite picture of
will that i call handy at all times
that's him stupid face
there he is at the smirk-a-thon
and he does a ton of these uh movies
and when would ride me constantly about
how they have not called
me i i might be the only person in town
that hasn't done a voice
um to to the point where when i did
finally get the call
uh i was so excited but then i
immediately thought somehow
he got to my agency called from there so
the phone number came up and he's
putting me up to it but right
but it it was real i made sure i called
him and told him that i got one
and then he just immediately told me
that he is currently working on one and
is negotiating for a sequel
of another one that he did so he always
has to talk you've got to top me
yeah um but i'm very proud of this one
this one is doing quite well the critics
are liking it the people are liking it
it's a great movie they know what
they're doing over there at disney
good lord do they know what they're
doing man they should they sure got to
you didn't they
balancing out the gay porn they got the
chip back in there
um they know what they're doing
yes no one makes a
movie like disney jason what's wrong
nothing's wrong
disney disney you um
is there a lot to it i always think that
it would be if you're in the voiceover
booth and i know andy's done voiceover
and he will again once his voice returns
but you uh or or it's
or it's over yeah but you you you've
done
uh is there a lot to it like i mean do
people work hardest does will arnett
does he work hard at it in the voice
over booth
um well he works hard he's got a stance
that i don't really understand he's he's
like
he's here he he what he does is he's
he's like the lead singer of like a
terrible 80s glam glam band he's got
like the microphone here
and he'll throw a foot in front of the
other one and he'll take a real balanced
stance like he's
about to rock the world with what he's
about to do and he'll put that dumb hand
up over one oh man
like not this but you don't need it at
all there's there's there's like a
suction thing
yeah but he'll do it he'll close his
eyes and he'll purse those dumb lips
and he'll just start to hiss it out a
little bit and he'll say no no no that's
not right let's keep it rolling
he he really grinds on it whereas you
know
if you're over there at disney where
they know what they're doing they know
what they're doing you just do
what you just whatever comes out of your
mouth they make it sound like velvet
yeah they're just incredible over there
best people i've ever heard
[Applause]
[Music]
god i wish i wish we had mickey mouse
ears right now we could pop on
you know what i want to do the next time
you're honest do the whole interview
just on this one camera
so jason how's it going it's good all
right
that'll be a whole new way to do the
show